[Musique]
et
c'est en présence des officiels que le
président du département série melchior
pose la première pierre de l'aménagement
du chemin stéphane rd 39 qui relie la
ligne des bambous à saint-pierre à la
ligne des 400 au tampon nous avions dit
à la population de saint pierre et du
tampon que le département va participer
à des travaux pour renforcer la sécurité
de tout le monde
chemin stéphane et bien aujourd'hui elle
en fait nous sommes là pour démarrer ses
travaux
ces travaux d'un coût de près de 6
millions d'euros pour mettre en sécurité
les usagers de la route mais aussi
toutes les cases des familles qui
habitent autour du chemin stéphane qui
étaient envahies par les eaux de pluie
le chemin stéphane c'est plus de 15000 à
20000 véhicules qui circulent
quotidiennement pour même tout
l'équipement
la commune a fait une bonne chose mais
le polir eux mêmes les voitures les
formateurs sont allemands cas si si
quand il ya là plus les voitures ont pu
monter avec les droits sur route
un projet de 21 millions d'euros dont
3,4 millions d'euros financés par le
département c'est la suppression de 5
radiés et l'aménagement de la route et
du réseau d'assainissement pour éviter
le refoulement des eaux dans les
quartiers du tampon nous donc et le but
de faciliter favoriser la circulation
c'est dur résoudre des problèmes du
penseur chemin stéphane d'autres pans
sur le chemin des 400 ce qui lui
permettra à terme de pour endiguer
facilement bien entendu la l'hypothèse
où les goulots d'étranglement qui se
trouve à l'entrée ça qu'il soit aussi
fait pas complètement et avec la
compréhension et de soutien pour
réaliser ces travaux prévue pour 12 mois
deux équipes travailleront simultanément
sur un linéaire de 2400 mètres entre
saint-pierre et le tampon et reste
important il y assure un câble
partenariat dans nos manuels six ter
entre les dix communes du sud
et cet exemple aujourd'hui et grands
messages lancés ensemble impressions du
sud continue à travailler ensemble comme
dit la tipa tipa l'arrivée
[Musique]